Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a drama fantasy film
called “Ricky.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with a tired mother of two
named Katie contemplating putting her baby
Ricky up for adoption. Katie works a low wage
job at a cosmetics factory and lives in welfare
housing in eastern Paris. She says she hasn’t
been able to look after Ricky and her daughter
Lisa by herself after her partner left her. The
social worker reminds her that abandoning a child
is a big decision and she should spend more
time making sure that she is taking the right
step. For the meantime, the social worker offers
to see if domestic help can be arranged for Katie
to help her look after the baby. Katie is
also advised to file a police report that
her baby’s father has abandoned her.
The movie then flashes back to the past
before baby Ricky was born. After waking up, Lily
opens the curtains and wakes up her perennially
tired mother. Lily then heads to the kitchen
and begins preparing breakfast for herself
and her mother. The mother-daughter then take
a shower and have breakfast together before
leaving for Lily’s school in Katie’s scooter.
Katie promises to pick her up later before
kissing her goodbye and heads to her work.
At the factory, Katie locks eyes with a man
named Paco Sanchez. Paco walks up to her during
a cigarette break and introduces himself. Katie
lends him a cigarette and Paco reveals that
he recently started working at the factory.
One thing leads to another and the two end
up hooking up in the washroom. As a result,
Katie takes time finishing her daily work quota
and gets in trouble with her boss who scolds her
for being lazy. Katie also arrives late to pick
up Lily from school. Moreover, she forgets to
bring Lily’s helmet and she is forced to give
Lily her own helmet on their ride back home.
The next day, Paco meets Katie outside the
factory. Katie expresses her embarrassment
over the fact that they hooked up right
after their first meeting, saying it is
usually not her style. Paco resonates with her,
saying he doesn’t hook up on first dates either.
After making some more small talk, Paco asks her
out on a date. Katie who has been longing for
company couldn’t be more excited and she accepts
the date, much to Lily’s dismay who wanted to
play dress-up with her mother. At the date, Paco
asks Katie about Lily’s father and she reveals
that he lives in southern france. Lily’s father
wanted Katie to abort her so he wants nothing to
do with Katie and their daughter. Meanwhile,
Paco reveals that he was briefly married in
Spain when he was young. After the date, Katie
takes him back home and the two make love again.
Poor Lily has a hard time falling asleep due to
the sound of Katie and Paco’s love making.
The next day, Lily wakes up to Katie and
Paco having breakfast together. Katie tries
to introduce her daughter to her date but the
little girl isn’t interested and she runs back
to her room. To spend more time with Paco, Katie
also signs Lily up for the school bus service
and Paco eventually moves into Katie’s home.
A year passes by and Katie becomes pregnant
with Paco's child. One day, Paco gets a
call at work from the hospital and learns
that Katie has unexpectedly gone into labor. He
rushes to be by Katie’s side with Lily. After
Katie gives birth to a healthy baby boy, Paco
asks Lily for suggestions for the baby’s name
and Lily names the baby Ricky. Paco turns Lily’s
room into a nursery, much to her dismay and she
begins to feel sidelined by her mother, who
spends most of her time with the new baby.
Lily also doesn’t like the fact that Katie
keeps insisting that Lily call Paco ‘dad’.
Katie spending most of her time looking after
the baby also begins to take a toll on her
relationship with Paco and one day, Lily
catches Paco cozying up to another woman
outside their apartment building. However,
Lily decides to keep it to herself.
Paco later returns home late, saying he was
out with his “friends”. Paco’s changed attitude
worries Katie and the two get into an argument.
However, the two make up before going to bed,
promising to be there for each other more.
Soon, Katie starts going to work again and
Paco is left to look after the baby during
the day. One day, when Katie returns home,
she notices a strange bruise on baby Ricky’s
back. She asks Paco about it but he denies
knowing anything about it. Paco insists that it’s
nothing but over the course of the next few days,
the baby grows another bruise on his back. The
poor baby also keeps crying all the time. One day,
Katie confronts Paco about the twin bruises.
Paco again denies knowing anything about it but
Katie accuses him of beating Ricky. This upsets
Ricky and he breaks up with her before leaving.
Seeing Paco storm out in anger, Lily realizes that
he has left for good and the little girl embraces
her mother to comfort her. With Paco out of the
picture, Lily becomes Ricky’s prime babysitter.
One day, Katie returns home to find Ricky missing
from his cradle, where the baby has left behind
a strange gooey mark. Lily and Katie frantically
look for the baby. Lo and behold, they locate the
baby on top of the closet. When they bring the
baby down, to their astonishment, they notice
two wings growing from Ricky’s shoulder blades.
It seems Ricky can move his wings which help him
levitate. Katie gives the baby a bath and wash the
blood off his little wings. She decides to keep
Ricky caged in his cradle to keep him from hurting
himself and she also warns Lily against saying
anything about Ricky in her school, fearing it
would only attract unnecessary attention towards
the baby. At times, Katie feels the urge to call
Paco but she can’t ever bring herself to do it.
Since developing the wings, Ricky sleeps well
and becomes cheerful. In one week, Ricky’s wings
grow 17 cm long and Katie designs a custom dress
for the baby. As time passes by, Ricky develops
feathers on his wings. One day, Paco randomly
shows up at Lily’s school and asks her about Katie
and Ricky. He also offers to take her home but
she declines the offer and gets on her bus.
As Ricky grows bigger, Katie buys a helmet and
knee pads for him so that he could fly without
hurting himself. Lily tries to tell Katie about
Paco but Katie interrupts her, saying since Ricky
started sleeping well, she has forgotten about
Paco. Things finally seem to be going good for
Katie and her family. She wins a 2000 Euro lottery
using which they go for Christmas shopping.
Unfortunately, when Lily and Katie are distracted,
Ricky manages to remove his jacket and starts
flying, horrifying the shoppers. Katie and Lily
run after the baby to stop him from hurting
himself. The authorities soon catch wind of the
strange baby and they shut down the entire store.
An entire army of police scramble to catch the
baby but without success. Eventually, on Katie’s
advice, they turn off the lights and baby Ricky is
finally caught. Katie is forced to take Ricky to a
hospital where doctors examine the baby. The head
doctor Bernard asks for Katie’s permission to keep
the baby in the hospital for further tests. He
also says that Ricky needs a spacious environment
to properly evolve. However, Katie declines the
offer and when she proceeds to take her baby home,
she is mobbed by people and the media,
desperate to catch a glimpse of the baby.
Several days pass by but the media continues to
camp outside Katie’s apartment complex. The flying
baby has become an international sensation.
One night, Ricky wouldn’t stop crying so Lily
lets him fly in his room unbeknownst to Katie who
is taking a shower. Suddenly, the doorbell rings
and it is revealed to be Paco. Lily calls out
for her mother who asks Lily to leave her alone
with Paco. Katie and Paco apologize to each
other and quickly rekindle their relationship,
much to Lily’s dismay. Lily expresses her concern
to her half brother who has flown over to the top
of the closet yet again. She is upset because she
feels that now that Paco is back again, Katie will
spend most of her time with him and Ricky.
Meanwhile, Paco reveals that all this time, he
worked in a restaurant in Paris. When Katie asks
if he had any affairs, he tells her that he hooked
up with one or two women but it wasn’t anything
serious. Later, Paco meets his son. Baby Ricky
doesn’t recognize his father and tries to fly
away when Paco attempts to hold him. Worried about
Ricky hurting himself, Katie calls him towards
herself but Paco’s presence scares the baby and
he refuses to come down. They eventually manage
to bring the baby down and Paco points out that
the room is too dangerous for Ricky to grow up in
but Katie tells him to shut up because she doesn’t
want to be separated from her son. They learn that
baby Ricky has hurt himself from all the flying
and they immediately call the doctor. Dr. Bernard
treats Ricky’s wound and reiterates Paco’s point.
He says that the apartment is not safe for
Ricky to grow up in. Dr. Bernard also suggests
a surgical procedure to remove Ricky’s wings,
which he calls safe but painful. However, Katie
refuses to put her baby through a surgery.
Later that night, Lily has the urge to cut
Ricky’s wings off with a pair of scissors
but before she goes through with it,
Paco arrives outside the room to kiss his son good
night, prompting Lily to run back to her bed.
The next day, over breakfast, Paco suggests
allowing the media to make a documentary on Ricky
in exchange for money. He says this would
give the family proper monetary resources
required to look after Ricky. This makes Katie
upset and she accuses Paco of returning back to
their life so he could make a buck off of
Ricky. However, Paco insists that he only
returned to look after his family and reminds
Katie how she previously baselessly accused
him of beating Ricky, asking her to trust
her this time. After a lot of convincing,
Katie gives him the permission to film Ricky.
The next day, on Paco’s request Dr.Bernard calls
the press in front of Katie’s apartment complex
for Ricky’s media debut. Katie and Paco present
themselves as a happy married family even though
they aren’t married. They also put a rope on
Ricky to keep him from flying away. To demonstrate
Ricky’s ability, they let go of him as Katie holds
the rope. The baby begins to fly like a bird much
to everyone’s astonishment. Katie is also excited
to see her baby fly so high for the first time
and as a result, she gets lost in the moment and
accidentally lets go of the rope. Ricky flies
away, prompting Katie and others to chase
after the baby. Passing through the lake, Ricky
flies into the woods. After waiting for a while,
the media loses interest in Ricky and leaves
but Katie refuses to move from her spot.
Dr. Bernad later joins Paco by the lake and
suggests that Ricky must have been shot by
a hunter or is starving to death somewhere.
Upset, Paco blames himself and laments that
Katie will never forgive him for this.
For the next few days, Katie and others
spend their time distributing missing posters
for Ricky around the market but in vain.
Several weeks pass by and others move on with
their life but Katie still longs for her son.
One day, she leaves her home for yet another
“walk” by the lake. It turns out the despondent
Katie has decided to end her life. However, as she
proceeds to drown herself, she hears Ricky's voice
and his flapping wings, as he returns.
Overjoyed, Katie runs towards her baby,
who has considerably grown up. The baby
looks happy and Katie apologizes to him,
saying that she let go of him because he looked
so happy in the air. The baby then flies away
and Katie realizes that Ricky’s happiness is in
the air. She returns home and lovingly embraces
her family after a long while.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.